teacher Luis Abreu is showing us around
a suburb in the north of Rio de Janeiro
he wants us to see what the local people
find extremely frustrating
a resident takes us to an abandoned
construction site this was supposed to
be a new school they stopped building
four years ago meanwhile the children
are being schooled in substandard
temporary classrooms they have to walk
through the favela which is dangerous
those who aren't finishing this building
are destroying the hopes and future of
our children the school ruin in South
schwow is symbolic
Brazil's infrastructure is getting
increasingly dilapidated the government
is doing little outside the upscale
neighborhoods
no one's investing anything here is
there really any public investment I
don't think so we walk through the
streets here and see that nothing is
being done
no one is investing any money we feel
betrayed the feeling of betrayal may
soon be getting worse the new finance
minister show Hakeem lavey has promised
to do everything he can to slash the
deficit and reduce inflation he's hoping
that will make Brazil more attractive to
investors that means cutting government
expenditure left and right critics like
economics professor victor aruz show
fear that will cause a snowball effect
when there's no investment no orders a
place that means less production and
fewer jobs our population is growing
each year we need more jobs and a
growing economy what's being planned
will destroy jobs with the country's
crumbling infrastructure and sputtering
economy at all show things the planned
austerity program will plunge
once-booming Brazil into a recession the
alternative would be the exact opposite
the government has to launch large-scale
investment plans that would create jobs
construction materials like sand and
concrete would be coming from local
businesses Luiz Abreu doesn't care where
the concrete might come from for the
school in South schwow
he just like construction to start again
he says everything is getting worse and
he doesn't believe the government's
forecast of economic growth in 2015